et oui le réquisitoire est d'une extrême
sévérité et c'est tout sauf une surprise
tant les charges qui pèsent contre jacky
martin sont lourdes étant le parcours
judiciaire de l'accusée est jalonnée par
de multiples condamnations
l'adn seule ne suffit pas pour
incriminer explique le parquet mais dans
ce dossier on retrouve les traces de
l'accusé sur le frein à main et la
ceinture de la voiture de la victime
plonger dans la saône le mobile c'est
l'agression sexuelle explique l'autre
représentante du parquet jupe retroussé
des traumatismes sur les parties intimes
voilà dans quel état on retrouvera le
corps de l'étudiante ce qui compte c'est
d'expliquer s'emporte l'avocat général à
aucun moment vous n'avez donner le
moindre début d'explication
jacky martens l'ignorent elle est dans
sa bulle
la famille giraud mais elle reste sans
réponse on écoute leur avocate
c'est pas supporter ça à la famille
d'anne sophie après ce qu'elle a déjà
enduré un deuxième procès ils sont
contraints de tours et entendre tout ce
qu'elle a subi toutes les agressions
pour tous ces coups qui lui ont été
portés dont j'attends une peine de
perpétuité pour que cet homme jamais
jamais une puisse recommencer
du côté de la défense pas fassiez le
voir impossible d'expliquer
l'inexplicable
la thèse d'un transfert d'adr un temps
évoquée a été balayé au cours de ce
procès par les experts adn reste le
doute qui selon la défense doit profiter
à l'accusé
les choses sont très claires en droit
français l'adn n'est pas la reine des
preuves ou c'est une reine des preuves
aux pieds d'argile c'est cela qui est
important
demain matin l'accusé prendra une
dernière fois la parole puis la cour
partir à délibérer pour la séquestration
et le meurtre d'anne sophie girollet à
mâcon en 2005
jacky martens aujourd'hui âgé de 58 ans
encourt une peine de réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité